la creuse et le pays de mon enfance
c'est un pays magnifique sauvage fait de
près de bois de landes de beaucoup de
rivières que vous connaissez peut-être
pas qui est coincé entre le limousin et
l'auvergne et c'est un endroit où il ya
plus je dirais de moutons et de vaches
que d'habitants
malgré tout magnifique quand on ya passé
son enfance et quel était mon plaisir là
en creuse c'était d'aller explorer les
échelons les immensités tout autour les
territoires passer d'eux
d'un endroit à un autre d'aller de plus
en plus loin d'aller un peu dans toutes
les directions et c'est là où j'ai
appris vraiment à me repérer à
m'orienter
et je pense qu'en fait ça m'a servi dans
le futur et dans mon métier comme tous
les petits garçons je vais explorait les
caves les greniers de mes parents et un
jour dans ce grenier extrêmement sombre
et un simple vasistas en eau pour
l'éclairer j'ai récupéré une pile de des
revues de mon père qui était chasseur
des revues de chasse et puis j'ai
feuilleté comme ça au hasard et je suis
tombé sur l'article l'article avec un
gras c'est veinules la sonde vénéra une
sonde russe qui venait d'atterrir sur
vénus et donc c'était ça a été un
élément déclencheur dans ma vie pour
l'exploration planétaire
la sonde vénéra il a réussi cet exploit
alors que la surface de vénus et à 460
degrés et à résister à cette température
pendant une heure donc c'était
véritablement un exploit et de là est
venue
vraiment c'est de cet instant-là de
cette lecture là qui est parti ma
passion pour l'exploration planétaire et
je dirais que c'était même au delà parce
que j'ai senti au plus profond de moi
même
instinctivement qu' il y avait ailleurs
dans l'espace dans l'univers des êtres
vivants comme nous peut-être pas aussi
évolué mais qui existaient et donc je
suis parti à leur recherche
donc on se rapproche et personnellement
je n'ai même pas abandonné l'idée qu'on
trouve possiblement de la vie même dans
le système solaire
alors peut-être pas sous une forme
évoluée sûrement pas mais
on la recherche sur marx actuellement on
la recherche sûre on va la rechercher
sur europe 1 on peut la rechercher sur
titan voilà il ya plein d'endroits dans
le système solaire où elle peut se
cacher dès lors qu'il ya de l'eau
liquide
je me suis dirigé donc vers l'astronomie
à cette époque-là en 1986 la comète de
halley revenait vers la terre vous en
êtes vous l'avez peut-être même vu elle
revient une fois tous les 76 ans est
donc la comète revenant vers la terre
les américains les européens les
japonais les russes se sont mis à
construire une sonde pour aller
l'explorer il ya eu une sorte de course
à la comète de halley et les européens
avec la sonde juno tôt l' agence
spatiale européenne a gagné cette course
si on peut dire
en passant plus près de la comète à
600km simplement de sa surface
donc c'était une mission courte de
quelques heures d'observation de
quelques minutes
mais pour la première fois on voyait une
comète de très très près j'ai été
intégré au centre national d'études
spatiales où j'ai travaillé sur un
projet de satellite d'observation
donc au bout de 13 ans ce programme
arrêtant je me suis dit qu'est ce que je
vais faire et là un miracle peut-être
mais quelqu'un quittait le projet
rosetta au ps et donc j'ai postulé et
j'ai pris sa place et donc je me suis
l'a senti complètement dans mon élément
j'étais pour la première fois
en train de véritablement aller faire de
l'exploration planétaire aller vers une
terra incognita une comète
pourquoi aller vers cette comète là et
quelle est la différence par exemple
avec jules otto que faire aux états ce
qui s'est passé avec joe tôt ces deux
trains qui se rend compte comme ça
qu'ils partent de deux endroits
différents
la comète à l'an 300 km heure le train
léger au taux allant à 200
kilomètres/heure elles se croisent et
l'instant d'observation et très court
avec rosetta
l'idée c'est que le train de la sonde
rosetta rattrape le train de la comète
donc on va arriver là comme est alors à
300 km heure on va arriver à 3 110
km/heure s'en rapprocher et puis à
partir d'un moment on va rester la
côtoyer et pouvoir l'observer sur la
durée et l'idée de rosetta c'est de
l'observer pendant au moins deux ans
alors pourquoi c'est si intéressant
d'aller voir une comète une comète c'est
un gros iceberg de glace un petit peu de
poussière dedans et aussi d'autres
molécules très intéressante qu'on
appelle des molécules prébiotiques site
qui serait possiblement avant la vie qui
ne sont pas comme des molécules vivante
qui se reproduisent mais des molécules
qui peuvent être à l'origine de la vie
et la théorie veut que on aille vers
enfin que cette ces comètes à un moment
donné de l'histoire du système solaire
sont venues frapper la terre la proto
terre où la terre en formation et former
une partie de l'eau de nos océans et en
amenant ses taux 'à aurait amené en même
temps les molécules prébiotiques et dans
l'océan terrestre à la bonne température
la vie aurait démarré sur terre alors
vous qui êtes là vous êtes vous le savez
formé de 70% d'eau et bien vous pourriez
très bien être formés 70% d'eau de kobe
est le 2 mars 2004 après avoir changé de
comètes nous partons en direction de
souriau mof des racines co mais
justement pour que le train rattrape la
comète il va falloir du temps le lanceur
n'étant pas capables de nous emmener
directement vers la comète
donc on va faire plusieurs tours dans le
système solaire survolé trois fois la
terre une fois mars en profité pour
s'envoler deux astéroïdes quand on
traverse la ceinture d'astéroïdes
et puis après en janvier février 2011
on donne un gros coup d'accélérateur
avec la sonde pascal a beaucoup de
carburant
et puis en juin 2014
mais juin 2014 un gros coup de freinage
on arrive vraiment à proximité
et finalement le 6 août 2014 donc il ya
pas longtemps on est arrivé à 100 km de
la comète et là on est en stationnaire
le train va rattraper l'autre les restes
est en train de l'observer et donc nous
avons observé la comète pendant trois
mois déjà
du point de vue scientifique c'était
très intéressant mais aussi pour repérer
l'endroit où on allait atterrir le 12
novembre 2004
on décide d'aller atterrir sur la comète
donc fida et file à l'essai un petit
robot mais c'est un petit satellite à
lui tout seul c'est un satellite avec
des jambes pour pouvoir atterrir et des
brins pour pouvoir se s'écarter de sa de
sa mère l'orbiteur aux états et donc on
se sépare
il faut voir que à ce moment là on est à
vingt mille kilomètres heure dans le
système solaire que ce soir aux états et
la comète est par contre la vitesse
relative de rosetta par rapport à la
comète et seulement 4 kilomètres la
vitesse à laquelle on peut au marché
donc c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
et donc on est en micro gravité et la
durée et la descente est une vraie chute
libre
elle va durer sept heures et au bout du
compte quand on va acquérir la calculer
très précisément on a aussi une vitesse
de 3 5 kilomètres très faible
malheureusement à ce moment là
filât est certes on ne vont pas
fonctionné et donc on va avoir un rebond
et au lieu de se trouver sur la lys air
d'été avec beaucoup de soleil on se
retrouve actuellement sur les mystères
d'hiver avec beaucoup d ombre donc pour
résumer la situation
la mission rosetta est un vrai succès
rosetta l'orbiteur continue à tourner
autour de la de la comète on est
maintenant à peu près trente mille
kilomètres heure par rapport au soleil
on s'est accélérée tout le monde s'est
accélérée et fila et lui est en
hibernation à la surface il y attend des
jours meilleurs et en effet comme on est
arrivé sur l'hémisphère sud on va
rentrer au printemps le 17 avril donc
très dans très peu de temps
et l'été sur commencera au mois d'août
donc tout va bien à la fois pour rosetta
et j'espère pour phil hay alors qu'elle
est là le bilan que je tire de tout ça
comment moi qui suis partie du bas du
plateau de millevaches
j'ai réussi à atterrir à 5 500 millions
de km de la terre
j'ai oublié de vous lier à 500 millions
de kilomètres de la terre est bien
est-ce que c'est purement un coup de
chance ou est ce que c'est le résultat
de deux points si denses telles que la
lecture d'un article dans le grenier de
mes parents eh bien il ya un petit peu
des deux je pense qu'en tout cas
il ya eu un facteur chance mais surtout
j'avais une trajectoire je mettais
donner une trajectoire extrêmement
précises dans la vie dans mes études et
dans ma vie professionnelle
quelque chose d'extrêmement précis de la
même façon que fille là et a atterri à
quelques mètres près de l'endroit prévu
avec une vitesse au centimètre près par
rapport à la vitesse prévue et un
instant donné près à quelques secondes
près du moment prévu je pense qu'il faut
toujours suivre son idée parmi des des
choix multiples qu'on a si on a une
passion en si on a un instinct il faut
toujours suivre cet instinct et être
vraiment obstiné sur ses choix
donc je souhaite à tous que vous
connaissiez grâce à moi l'origine de la
vie sur une comète qui se trouve à 500
millions de kilomètres de là je vous
remercie